[Music]
with about fifty days until the
presidential election national security
specifically terrorism is clearly going
to be at the forefront of many people's
minds when they go into the ballot box
in November the last year is seen the
slow creep of terrorism become the new
normal which none of us want to accept
it's nothing short of a miracle that
nobody died in the recent bombings in
New York City or New Jersey or in the
stabbing spree in Minnesota mall despite
no casualties the victims and those
around them will forever be scarred
another victim aside from the actual
people who were directly affected by
these attacks is our political debate
around terrorism to be clear 2016 isn't
exactly the year for constructive
political debate but the terrorism
discussion and the passion it brings up
are almost guaranteed to bring out the
worst in people so let me just back up
here for a moment and try to state
something as clearly as humanly possible
for roughly the three billion time there
is a difference between the doctrine of
Islam which is just a set of ideas and
Muslims the people who practice it the
doctrine has all kinds of terrible stuff
in it but this doesn't mean all the
people who call themselves Muslims
believe in or act upon those bad ideas
however it has become pretty clear that
a subset of Muslims do act upon these
ideas and this is what has led us to
worldwide jihad from Orlando to Brussels
to Paris to Jerusalem to Sydney there is
almost no country Islamic terrorism
hasn't already affected or is in trying
to affect this isn't a coincidence it's
actually the stated plan of the jihadist
before I continue yes I do acknowledge
that there is plenty of bad stuff in the
other holy books God is a real piece of
work in the Old Testament to say the
least but the simple truth is that in
the many Christian nations out there or
in the one Jewish nation minorities are
treated better than in any country where
Islam is the
an ideology think of every secular
society out there the US Britain France
Germany Sweden or Japan none of them are
perfect but all of them basically treat
their citizens equally under the law
this doesn't mean discrimination and
inequality don't exist but it does mean
that secular rule is better than
religious rule now think of the many
Islamic societies out there
Iran Qatar Egypt Saudi Arabia how's it
going for women in those countries how's
it going for gays for Jews for atheists
or for Christians or for literally
anyone who isn't Muslim you know the
answer and it's not good yes there are
geopolitical reasons adding to why the
Middle East is screwed up but this
doesn't diminish the fact that where
Islam takes root every other idea is
systematically destroyed Christianity in
the Middle East is all but gone except
in Israel and I'm pretty sure you know
how jihadists feel about that place
where Islam is in power it's bad for
everyone except Muslims and actually in
most cases it's bad for Muslims too
specifically for some within the Muslim
community like the affer mentioned
atheist free thinkers women or gays
I'm sure the usual hacks and apologists
will say I'm somehow being Islamophobic
now allow me to quote the late great
Christopher Hitchens on his feelings
about the word Islamophobia quote
Islamophobia is a word created by
fascists and used by cowards to
manipulate morons end quote
now allow me to expand on that just a
bit a phobia is an irrational fear is it
irrational to fear an ideology which
would throw gays off roofs behead
infidels force women to wear burqas and
kill and maim scores of innocence in
terror attacks all over the world I
think not
the more we censor ourselves for the
fear of being called a bigot or a racist
the more that Islam will encroach on our
secular values tolerance is a two-way
street but where on earth in 2016 is
Islam tolerant of any of us again this
doesn't mean there aren't millions of
Muslim people who practice their faith
privately like my friend Maajid Nawaz or
enjoy the cultural
aspects of being Muslim like my friend
Ali rizvi what it does mean however is
that any set of ideas that wouldn't
tolerate you isn't worth being tolerated
itself tolerance of intolerance is a
slow death so now back to the events of
the past few days sadly these terror
attacks are becoming all too common in
America whether a shooting in San
Bernardino or Orlando or a bombing in
Boston or New York City the world is
changing right before our eyes and to
pretend that jihad an ideology whose
stated goal is world domination isn't
really serious
well that isn't just stupid it's
actually dangerous shooting stabbings
and bombings are all designed to kill
and maim any and all of us when a bomb
goes off it doesn't care if you're a
right-wing Christian or a flag-burning
lefty it's designed to shred the fabric
of our societies not pick and choose
which of us are the good ones so while
the apologists for Islam will continue
obfuscating and denying that won't spare
them from relentless jihad and those of
us not talking about this for fear of
being called a bigot or a racist or
actually inviting more violence in May
them afraid to speak your mind today
well where are you gonna be in five or
ten years if you won't speak up now
having this type of complex conversation
is what we've tried to respectfully do
on the Rubin report with people from all
over the political map I wasn't planning
on doing a direct message on terrorism
this week but unfortunately carne events
don't wait for your permission to happen
while mainstream media debates skittles
and the Brangelina divorce I'll continue
to try to navigate through the noise in
a more thoughtful and constructive way
sharing your ideas is simply the most
important thing you can do in a Western
secular society it's something every
single person in a closed society wishes
they could do yet we so often take it
for granted it's one thing to be afraid
of being killed in a terror attack but
it's another thing to be afraid to speak
up so speak up now while you still can
[Music]
you